as you dream up your ideas it is
important to be passionate about them it
is never a good idea to create a star up
just because you want to create a star
up create a star because you want to
solve a problem that keeps you up at
night
successful companies start from a good
idea and a good idea might be one of
these things solve a novel problem
Google did that with search extend the
current solution Udacity does that by
providing an affordable on-demand
technical education for jobs disrupt an
industry uber provides an easier way to
share a ride in the next video
Chris is going to share types of idea
that might help you come up with your
idea